[Musique]
politique bonsoir bienvenue dans les
deux politiques votre rendez-vous du
dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec télé 78 épisode 222 mon
invité ce soir et la porte-parole du
Parti socialiste est conseillère
régional guide de France diebab
[Musique]
de politique
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes donc
porte-parole du Parti socialiste et
conseiller régional d'Île-de-France et
également mère adjointe de la ville des
Mureaux dans les Yvelines beaucoup de
sujets abordés avec vous ce soir aussi
bien nationaux que régionaux le budget
la réforme des retraites les violences
sexistes et sexuelles mais aussi le
nouveau plan d'adaptation au changement
climatique de la région
Île-de-France ou encore la probable
augmentation du Pass Navigo pour les
Franciliens mais d'abord dianaba job
parlons de l'Italie la semaine dernière
Georgia Meloni et son parti Fratelli
Italia ont remporté donc les élections
législatives lui permettant avec une
coalition de ballon de la droite à
l'extrême droite de prendre la tête du
pays une performance que certains ont
tenté de réaliser en France pour vous
qu'est-ce qu'elle représente cette
victoire de Giorgia Meloni en Italie je
crois que c'est victoire de Georgia
Mélanie en Italie doit tous nous
interpellé c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
on sait que l'extrême droite arrive au
pouvoir et je crois que ça c'est très
inquiétant puisque ce n'est pas
seulement l'Italie on a aussi le cas de
la Suède Victor Hormann est installé
depuis un bon bout de temps aussi
en gris donc je crois que et nous savons
que nous avons évité de peu que
l'extrême droite puisse
arrivé au pouvoir aussi dans notre pays
l'arrivée massive de 89 députés dans
notre assemblée doit aussi être un cri
d'alerte moi je crois que chacun doit
prendre ses responsabilités et on doit
rappeler à nos concitoyens ce qu'est
l'extrême droite Georgia Mélanie se
réclame de Mussolini ce n'est pas une
poste fasciste c'est une néophagie
c'est-à-dire que c'est une nouvelle
forme de fascisme c'est-à-dire avec tout
ce qu'elle a de de dénigrement de
l'autre de xénophobie de justement de ce
qu'elle porte qui est contraire aux
valeurs de notre République qui est
aussi contraire aux valeurs de l'Europe
d'ailleurs
Ursula van der lionne l'avait rappelé
lors de son discours en disant que
l'arrivée de justement d'une telle
coalition à la tête de l'Italie était un
très mauvais comme on dirait je signale
pour notre continent il faut pas oublier
aussi que à l'heure où nous avons
justement cette guerre en Ukraine c'est
arriver de ces coalitions faites de
droite et d'extrême droite sont aussi
des soutiens potentiels à la politique
menée justement par Vladimir Poutine
donc je nous invite vraiment à la plus
grande vigilance et c'est aussi pour
cela que ça peut paraître anecdotique
mais c'est aussi pour cela que les
députés socialistes ont refusé de jouer
avec les députés du rassemblement
national parce que on doit pas
participer à la banalisation d'extrême
droite lors du match de foot donc
exactement cette semaine vous l'avez
noté c'est là c'est le quatrième
gouvernement d'extrême droite en Europe
après la Hongrie la Pologne et la Suède
plus récemment c'est un avertissement à
ne pas prendre à la levure selon vous en
vue des européennes de 2024 les
élections qui vont avoir lieu dans dans
maintenant un peu moins de 2 ans
évidemment je crois que c'est une alerte
que nous devons prendre très au sérieux
parce que ça veut dire que petit à petit
mais il faut aussi le rappeler grâce à
des coalitions avec la droite il y a une
dynamique de l'extrême droite mais elle
n'est possible que lorsque la droite tu
fais la courte échelle extrême droite
seul ne peut rien à chaque fois qu'elle
accède de pouvoir c'est parce que une
partie de la droite oublie ses valeurs
et
se dit que finalement ça n'est pas si
grave de faire une coalition avec
l'extrême droite or il est toujours
extrêmement grave de faire des
coalitions avec l'extrême droite la
l'histoire et surtout l'histoire de
notre continent de l'Europe des sortes
de notre pays nous oblige on doit jamais
oublier ce qu'est l'extrême droite
l'extrême droite ce sont les rafles du
Vél' d'hives l'extrême droite c'est
aussi des personnes qui sont poursuivies
discriminés voire tuer parce qu'elles
sont différentes parce qu'elles ont une
origine différente parce qu'elles ont
une orientation sexuelle différente ce
n'est pas ce ne sont pas les valeurs que
nous portons en Europe donc il va
falloir être en capacité d'avoir une
proposition justement politique qui soit
à la hauteur des attentes des
européennes et des Européens dans ce
moment tellement difficile donc le
rendez-vous est pris en 2024 pour ces
élections européennes en France cette
semaine le futur budget 2023 a été
présenté par Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie et Gabriel Attal le ministre
des contes publics on parle d'un budget
protecteur et dépensier c'est ce qui est
avancé la majorité des ministères voit
leur budget augmenter en premier lieu
celui du travail qui passe de 14,5 à
20,7 milliards d'euros et le financera
l'apprentissage la formation des
chômeurs ou encore l'Agence France
travail le nouvel Pôle emploi que
pensez-vous de ce premier signe de donc
le ministère du Travail et le ministère
qui voit son budget le plus augmenté
alors oui son budget augmente mais le
problème c'est que
ce n'est pas à la hauteur de la
situation que l'on a aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a une inflation tout le
monde le tout le monde le voit qui est
absolument énorme avec des hausses de
prix qui sont à peu près enfin qui sont
bien supérieurs à justement
les boucliers qui sont mis en place ce
qui se passe c'est que ce bouclier
tarifaire en fait c'est un aveu d'échec
parce qu'en fait on ne peut pas
combattre les problèmes que l'on a
aujourd'hui avec des rustines même si on
augmente effectivement le budget et ça
va dans le bon sens le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est une
augmentation des salaires si vous
n'augmentez pas les salaires vous
n'augmenterez pas le pouvoir d'achat des
Françaises et des Français vous avez
aussi une explosion justement de la
facture énergétique pas seulement pour
les Françaises et les français mais
aussi pour les collectivités
territoriales qu'en est-il quelles sont
les compensations qui vont être versées
aux collectivités territoriales moi je
suis mère adjo comme vous l'avez rappelé
sur la ville des Mureaux on sait très
bien que notre facture énergétique dans
les écoles dans les établissements
publics elle va exploser comment fait-on
nous ne bénéficions pas par exemple de
d'un tarif qui soit qui soit encadrés
comme le comme on peut en bénéficier
lorsque vous êtes un citoyen alors alors
que nous sommes du service public vous
voyez il y a plein
on dit qu'il y a de la bonne volonté
mais le problème de ce gouvernement
c'est qu'il ne voit pas la réalité du
terrain et donc les propositions qu'il
fait ne sont pas en phase avec les
besoins sur l'augmentation des salaires
vous en parliez pour l'éducation
nationale une une enveloppe de 935000
euros ce sera consacrer donc au
revalorisation du salaire des
enseignants c'était dans le programme
dan Hidalgo d'ailleurs lors de la
campagne présidentielle de 2022 donc
j'imagine que cette enveloppe pour vous
l'accueillez à bras ouverts
je vous rappelle que Anne Hidalgo a été
raillé d'ailleurs au départ lorsqu'elle
a parlé justement du doublement des
salaires
justement on n'est pas sur un doublement
des salaires mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que cette enveloppe là encore
c'est une rustine le problème qu'on va
avoir c'est que aujourd'hui pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a aussi peu de personnes
qui veulent s'engager sur la voie de
l'enseignement moi-même je suis
enseignante ça fait 24 ans que j'exerce
ce métier les conditions dans lesquelles
nous travaillons mon cessé de se
dégrader pourquoi parce que il y a
beaucoup trop
en termes d'effectif le compte n'y est
pas en termes de rénovation des locaux
le compte n'y est pas en terme de
salaire lorsque vous voyez que il y a eu
un gel d'indice et ça tout gouvernement
confondu depuis des années et des années
c'est très bien qu'on fasse un meilleur
départ en termes de carrière pour celles
et ceux qui pourraient avoir l'envie et
justement de ressusciter des des
vocations mais qu'en est-il de celles et
ceux qui travaillent dans l'éducation
nationale depuis des années qui vont
voir eux leur salaire qui n'aura pas
évolué ou encore très peu et à côté de
ça des personnes qui parfois ont été
recrutés en 5 minutes je vous rappelle
on a fait du job dating dans au rectorat
de Versailles moi j'ai vu des collègues
arrivés avec des des qualifications qui
n'étaient pas à la hauteur de ce que
l'on peut attendre et regarder quel
message on envoie aux personnes qui ont
un bac + 5 qui ont passé un concours à
qui on a eu des exigences ce qui est
normal pour notre jeunesse et à côté de
ça
[Musique]
dans les équipements très nouveau
rafales un second sous-marin nucléaire
18 chars Leclerc rénovés des
investissements qui concerneront aussi
l'espace le renseignement la
cyberdéfense des tailles donc le
ministère de Bercy c'est important de
montrer les muscles vu la situation et
le contexte international la défense
doit-elle être selon vous une priorité
également oui c'est peut-être aussi une
priorité effectivement on est dans un
contexte compliqué je l'ai rappelé avec
une guerre en Ukraine qui concerne toute
l'Europe et pas seulement la Russie et
l'Ukraine parce que elle dit beaucoup
aussi de la volonté impérialiste ou des
nouvelles ou que d'autres pourraient
aussi avoir donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être extrêmement vigilant
effectivement la défense est importante
mais moi je veux aussi parler de du
budget qui doit concerner justement
notre police il faut aussi donner à la
police la moyenne d'exercer
convenablement on sait très bien qu'il y
a outre la présence physique effective
nous sommes la police de proximité il
faut aussi qu'il y ait que nos agents et
les moyens un d'être équipés
convenablement deux de aussi on oublie
souvent de pouvoir se loger correctement
lorsque vous êtes un agent des forces
publiques et que vous travaillez par
exemple à Paris on sait très bien que ce
logia à Paris ça n'est pas facile se
loger dans les grandes villes ça n'est
pas facile il faut qu'il y ait des
mesures pour que nos agents puissent
être logés correctement qui puisse aussi
bénéficier par exemple de mode de garde
adapté à leur
à leur fonction et aussi à leurs
horaires je crois que c'est un ensemble
de choses qui doit être fait et donc on
va dans le bon sens sur la défense mais
il ne faut pas oublier aussi la
proximité la police du quotidien et être
tout simplement dans le cadre du service
public en général donner les moyens au
fonctionnaires justement de de d'être au
service des concitoyens des contenus
dans de bonnes conditions dans
l'actualité politique aussi la réforme
des retraites
Macron veut accélérer mais du côté de la
majorité on veut éviter tout passage en
force écouter Alexis Isard député
renaissance de l'Essonne c'était la
semaine dernière dans les deux
politiques concerté discuter essayer de
convaincre les oppositions a priorité et
la concertation et le travail avec les
oppositions visiblement les oppositions
pour l'instant n'ont pas envie de
travailler avec nous n'ont pas envie
d'avancer je vois mal cependant un
électorat de droite s'opposer à une
réforme des retraites qu'il porte depuis
des années donc je crois que le travail
de le travail de discussion le travail
de concertation il doit être mené
fermement avec ses partenaires là quitte
à faire des avancées dans leur sens hein
c'est vraiment le coeur de cette de
cette concertation c'est le cœur de la
de la consultation c'est pour ça qu'il
faut travailler ensemble et j'ai bonne
confiance qu'on arrive à trouver un
terrain d'entente sur ces sujets là si
c'est pas le cas il faudra avancer il
faudra avancer dit-il cette réforme
aujourd'hui beaucoup critiques sont
utilité quelle est la position du PS là
dessus est-ce qu'il faut tout de même
une réforme mais pas celle du
gouvernement ou un statu quo vous
convient alors effectivement il faut
certainement une réforme mais pas celle
du gouvernement il faut savoir que cette
réforme en plus d'être injuste elle est
inutile je vous rappelle que aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce que on peut nous dire
c'est que suite à la réforme qui avait
été faite en 2013 en fait on avait fait
justement des réserves qui ont été
créées par Lionel Jospin grâce aux
réserve des régimes complémentaires
notre système est absolument pas
déficitaire il est même excédentaire on
l'a dit on l'a rappelé pendant pendant
pendant la campagne c'est quand même 150
milliards d'euros de réserves donc il y
a pas d'urgence à réformer maintenant le
problème qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est que
si on fait un report de l'âge légal on
va pénaliser les personnes qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt parce que ils
ont des des carrières longues de la même
manière je vous rappelle que lorsque
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au pouvoir
une des premières choses qu'il a fait
c'est de retirer les critères de
pénibilité que nous avions mis en place
pour prendre en compte justement ces
carrières qui sont dans des métiers
difficiles avec une pénibilité on n'a
pas la même pénibilité lorsqu'on est
enseignant ou quand on est justement
éboueur ou quand on travaille dehors
avec les BTP c'est pas du tout la même
la même pénibilité donc nous on veut
bien qu'il y ait une réforme on peut il
peut y avoir aussi des pistes par
exemple augmenter les taux de
cotisations patronales pour équilibrer
le système etc il y a pas de fatalité
justement au décalage de l'âge de départ
mais c'est un choix politique et puis
l'autre chose sur lesquelles on est
opposé c'est que cette réforme elle elle
va aussi sur une réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
acceptable quand on voit que
effectivement elle va pénaliser les
personnes qui sont au chômage depuis
longtemps on a cette espèce de
suspicion toujours que les gens ne
veulent pas aller travailler c'est pas
le cas il faut accompagner les personnes
qui sont au chômage je peux vous assurer
que les personnes qui sont au chômage
pour être une élue la proximité ils ont
pas envie d'y rester ils veulent
travailler donc il faut muscler les
outils pour pouvoir les accompagner
est-ce que l'on fait là c'est simplement
des vieux réflexes de droite et enfin
juste pour répondre à Monsieur Isa quand
il nous dit que l'opposition ne fait pas
travailler ne veut pas avancer et qui ne
voit pas comment par contre les
oppositions de droite pourraient ne pas
voter c'est normal je vous rappelle que
elle REM c'est aussi un parti de droite
il faut là il faut quand même leur
rappeler donc c'est normal qu'il soit
d'accord maintenant la gauche elle est
prête à discuter elle est prête
justement à participer à cette
concertation si et seulement si le
gouvernement est prêt à entendre ce que
nous avons à proposer cette réforme pour
avoir d'autres conséquences puisque les
oppositions donc menaces de voter une
motion de censure et le président de la
République a lui aussi menacé donc en
réaction cette semaine d'une dissolution
de l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que ça
vous fait peur au PS non ça ne nous fait
pas peur après je crois que il va
falloir rappeler au président de la
République on est en démocratie
l'Assemblée nationale c'est un endroit
où justement on doit discuter alors
effectivement ça lui fait tout drôle
parce que en France on n'est pas habitué
à avoir une majorité relative c'est à
dire que nous sommes un des rares pays
d'ailleurs on a on est un des rares
exemples dans le monde où il n'y a pas
où on a eu pendant très longtemps cette
majorité absolue qui donnait tous les
pouvoirs à l'exécutif et bien moi je me
réjouis que l'Assemblée nationale
retrouve son rôle c'est à dire celui du
débat démocratique c'est un endroit où
on doit discuter des lois des projets de
loi et puis de faire des réformes en
concertation justement le gouvernement
doit aller chercher justement la
majorité et bien pour cela il faut
qu'elle prenne en compte ce que
l'opposition a à dire et je pense que
c'est très simple pour notre démocratie
les violences sont vers les femmes ont
rattrapé aussi la nupais ça après
l'affaire cadenas c'est au tour de
Julien Bayou qu'au président du groupe
ELV à l'Assemblée nationale de présenter
donc sa démission il reste lui aussi
député et conseiller régional
d'Île-de-France comme vous d'ailleurs je
ne souhaite pas donc on revienne sur
toutes ces affaires qui ont été
largement pour le commenter mais sur le
fond le débat sur les violences sexistes
et sexuelles a fait beaucoup de chemin
sa dernière année vous que ce que vous
l'avez noté depuis vos débuts en
politique oui indéniablement je crois
qu'on peut remercier toutes les
associations qui ont aidé justement à
mettre en lumière
justement la réalité de ce que vivent
beaucoup de femmes
dans la dans notre société et cette
espèce de violence qu'elles peuvent
subir évidemment avec le paroxysme des
féminicides mais aussi c'est violence
sexiste des mots déplacés du harcèlement
je crois que nous avons tous progressé
puisque nous avons aussi au sein des
différentes composantes politiques créer
des cellules de veille d'écoute pour
justement être en capacité de répandre
de répondre pardon aux demandes de
lorsque elles sont formulées de jeunes
femmes ou de femmes lorsqu'elles ont
besoin justement de libérer leurs
paroles qu'elle puisse être écoutées
qu'elle puisse être mise à l'abri de
mettre en retrait celui qui peut être
mis en cause et de laisser effectivement
et de saisir la justice lorsque c'est
nécessaire ou d'aider à accompagner la
victime pour qu'elle puisse saisir la
justice je crois qu'on a fait beaucoup
de chemin parce que ce sont des choses
qui n'existaient pas dans la plupart des
formations politiques on sait très bien
que lorsque vous êtes une femme vous
pouvez très rapidement avoir droit à des
remarques déplacées lorsque vous prenez
la parole on peut avoir aussi des
siffler on l'a vu à l'Assemblée
nationale enfin je veux dire même des
gens qui sont des représentants de la
République ce sont laissés aller à des
comportements complètement inadmissibles
et inacceptables donc je crois qu'on a
fait du chemin ça n'est pas suffisant il
faut continuer à accompagner les
victimes et il faut continuer dans le
pouvoir public à ce qu'elle soit
recueillie de manière complètement
confidentielle puis de manière en toute
confiance pour qu'elle puisse aller au
bout de leur marche lorsqu'elle les
effectue c'est le moment de passer à la
deuxième partie de l'hebdopolitique on
va s'intéresser avec vous à l'actualité
de la région Île-de-France
[Musique]
toujours avec dianaba job porte-parole
du Parti socialiste et conseillère
régional d'Île-de-France la région
justement à voter un plan régional
d'adaptation au changement climatique un
milliard d'euros seront investis jusqu'à
2030 pour financer 60 actions parmi
lesquelles la plantation de 2 millions
d'arbres en milieu urbain 1000 points
d'eau seront également financés pour
résister aux canicules la région
accompagnera également à 50% les projets
des particuliers qui souhaitent
installer chez eux des récupérateurs
d'eau de pluie alors c'est la première
fois qu'une région donc lance un plan de
la sorte c'est c'est une bonne chose que
les régions
s'investissent et prennent en compte ces
sujets oui effectivement je pense qu'il
faut il faut absolument se prendre en
compte ces sujets et puis après l'été
que nous avons passé on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui être plusieurs vagues de
canicule exactement des inondations des
crues effectivement on a vu le métro
aussi subir effectivement les
intempéries on ne pouvait pas passer à
côté effectivement c'est une bonne chose
maintenant le problème que nous avons
avec ce plan c'est que c'est voilà voté
par la majorité régionale c'est que
c'est un plan le problème c'est que
comme à l'habitude de cette majorité
beaucoup d'annonces mais concrètement où
aller l'argent comment on fait un
milliard en fait j'ai envie de vous dire
que
chez Valérie Pécresse c'est une habitude
à chaque problème un milliard le
problème c'est que le milliard il est
souvent invisible par exemple il y avait
un milliard qui devait être donné sur le
Val-d'Oise il attend toujours sur les
transports on attendait la révolution
c'est pas le cas moi je veux bien
qu'effectivement on fasse des plans
d'adaptation mais qu'il faut qu'on soit
concret ça veut dire que aujourd'hui
comment est-ce que on est en capacité
d'agir concrètement d'adapter d'adapter
sérieusement nos politiques publiques
lorsque on n'est pas en capacité par
exemple d'être à la hauteur de l'enjeu
la réalité et qui soit efficace moi je
crois que on ne peut pas faire justement
des incantations on a des problèmes un
milliard par-ci un milliard par là
effectivement nous on a voté pour les
mesures qui vont dans la direction la
bonne direction parce que on n'est pas
une opposition bête et méchante avec des
postures politiciennes mais on dit qu'il
faut aller plus loin on a fait un
certain nombre d'amendements justement à
ce budget que j'ai pas détaillé ici
parce que ça va être trop long mais que
j'invite à retrouver sur notre site
idfc serait que on a fait des
propositions moi je crois que
sincèrement si Valérie Pécresse elle
veut avoir un vrai plan d'adaptation
climat qu'elle arrête d'annoncer des
milliards à tour de bras qu'elle
consulte vraiment son opposition et
qu'on aille sur le fond qu'on travaille
sur les transports qu'on travaille sur
effectivement les équipements que l'on
travaille sur justement à ne pas
augmenter le Pass Navigo puisque c'est
ce qu'elle agite comme comme menace par
exemple sur les transports puisque vous
en parler cette semaine a été marqué une
nouvelle fois par une nouvelle grève à
la RATP une grève qui a été organisée
par la CGT dans un contexte de
fortination et de pénurie de chauffeur
de bus il manquait fin août 4000
chauffeurs dans toute la France il en
manquerait aujourd'hui à la RATP entre
700 et 800 alors la région justement
Valérie Pécresse annoncé cette semaine
la création d'une prime de 2000 € pour
tout jeune qui se lancerait dans une
formation de chauffeur de bus donc pour
essayer d'attirer donc et de manquer
donc à cette pénurie une bonne idée
selon vous une bonne idée sauf que là
tout de suite concrètement ça va pas
changer notre problème parce que c'est
Gênes ils ont besoin d'être formés et
que le temps qu'il soit formé on va
toujours avoir trois mois de formation
donc elle estime que en janvier ça
devrait être réglé bien écoutez on verra
en janvier si si c'est réglé mais le
problème est toujours le même c'est que
dans les services notamment dans les
services publics même le problème que
l'on a aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
ces postes ne sont pas attractifs si on
en vient à donner une prime de 2000
euros pour que les gens se disent ah bah
tiens j'ai gagné 2000 euros avant même
d'avoir commencé ma formation ça pose un
problème ça veut dire que le niveau de
salaire n'est pas attractif je le dis et
je le redis si on veut justement pallier
les problèmes de recrutement il faut
qu'en face le métier qui soit proposé il
faut qu'il y ait une grille de salaire
qui soit suffisamment attractive il faut
que le travail paye c'est la seule
solution pour qu'on retrouve justement
un niveau d'attractivité qui soit
justement suffisant et pour finir donc
ça m'amène à parler maintenant du passe
Navigo que vous avez qui juste avant la
présidente de la région de France a
indiqué quand l'État est vu
l'augmentation donc des prix de
l'énergie elle sera contrainte
d'augmenter le prix Navigo de 25 euros
donc on passera on passe Navigo à 100
euros par mois le Pass n'avait pas
augmenté depuis 5 ans on est bien loin
des débats lors des régionales avec
aurait pu le voir qui militait pour la
gratuité des transports en commun on en
est très loin et puis surtout on est
loin des promesses de Valérie Pécresse
qui avait dit qu'elle ne toucherait pas
à la tarification du passe Navigo donc
je la renvoie à cette à cet engagement
qu'elle avait qu'elle avait tenu moi je
pense que le chantage à l'augmentation
n'est pas la solution je crois qu'elle
doit déjà s'occuper du dérapage par
exemple la Île-de-France mobilité de de
1 milliard 7 du budget du RER E à notre
initiative et je salue d'ailleurs
Jean-Marc Germain qui a porté avec nous
mon collègue la mission de l'information
surréal parce que nous voulions
comprendre comment on a pu arriver à un
dérapage de 1 milliard 7 j'en veux pour
preuve que aujourd'hui le directeur de
la SNCF a été limogé et qu'il va falloir
aussi que justement on mette un peu
d'ordre dans dans cette dans cette
gestion moi ce que je dis tout
simplement c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
transports ils pourraient être gratuit
au moins pour nos étudiants et pour nos
jeunes parce que on sait très bien que
c'est un poste de dépenses extrêmement
important que ça va assigner à résidence
un certain nombre de citoyens et si on
veut effectivement aller vers une région
vertueuse qui veut justement être en
adaptation au changement climatique ça
passe par des transports et ça passe
aussi par de la gratuité merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle donc
que vous êtes la porte-parole du parti
réaliste et conseillère régional
d'Île-de-France nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de l'hebdopolitique bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
les deux politiques